good morning everyone and welcome to
Columbia welcome to this wonderful event
a beautiful morning and welcome to the
world leaders forum we are very
fortunate this morning to be joined by
Vice President Mohammad youssuf kala of
the Republic of Indonesia and I'd like
to thank Columbia's Weatherhead East
Asian Institute for co-sponsoring this
event and Andy Nathan sitting in the
front row here class of 1919 professor
of political science for moderating the
question-and-answer session that will
follow the the vice president's remarks
and I'd like to also acknowledge
ambassador bodybow Alex Ono and and the
members of the Indonesian delegation and
their their their their clothes are much
more interesting than us guys in suits
they've got beautiful shirts that I
really attack them for coming in there
Indonesian shirts vice-president kala is
a longtime public servant having at
different points in his career been a
member of parliament Minister of Trade
and minister of welfare he assumed his
current office in 2014 he is also an
accomplished businessman and a trained
economists for the past eight years mr.
Callaghan chair of Indonesia's Red Cross
Society the topic of his speech today
middle path Islam for harmony and peace
the Indonesian experiences of great
interest to us all nearly 250 million
people speaking more than 300 languages
live on Indonesia's thousands of islands
the nation is home to the world's
largest Muslim population and has
Southeast Asia's largest economy
Indonesia's experience with
representative democracy is relatively
recent beginning at the turn of this
century and coming after many years of
colonial rule and an authoritarian
governance since making that transition
the country has been a stable and
tolerant society with free and fair
elections a secular Constitution and a
principles leader in president Joko
Widodo indonesia nevertheless faces the
challenge of preserving open discourse
and a pluralistic society while managing
substantial national security concerns
and the injection of religious fervor
into its politics
the threat of the Islamic state within
Indonesia is real and though the police
are effective in porting terrorist plots
there remains lingering concern about
Isis recruits returning from Syria
Indonesia has recently seen an increase
in political support for Islamic
conservatives and repeated calls for the
adoption of Sharia law when the
Christian governor of Jakarta was found
guilty of blasphemy
earlier this year moderates in the
country said that the conviction had
damaged the integrity of the judiciary
and was a setback for religious
tolerance and freedom of speech we have
invited president vice president kala
today to discuss these tensions and a
host of cross-cutting issues facing his
country please join me in welcoming him
to the podium
[Applause]
Thank You Sherman and props are and
audience good morning good every morning
we come here and in I using buttocks
because the way there's too good to hear
for me and we hope that there you can
enjoy it exist this good days here in
New York first of all first of all let
me say that I you're thinking what I
should say T to good morning but as
moderator say that one of this good
agenda is how why Islamic war and why
Indonesia sumo stable compared with many
countries in Asia and the Middle East in
many part of the world sometimes wall is
very noisy now on including from here
very noisy and for some time we don't
understand what should be to say about
in Twitter
I think the first egg for the university
is invite him to speak it's miss morning
I'm s dimensions a new data say that
Indonesia consisting of two thousand
sixty two hundred thousand sixty million
people's his numbers for after us they
says we are very close in number of
populations in which the same - we are
very so many races so many language and
so many different only thing that
America is continent and Indonesia is
archipelago or consider different that
various way sometimes different way how
to manage this archipelago compared
Continentals likes Europe or in its us
in Indonesia but we enjoy it this way
before they say we are separated by
ocean but I said no we are united by by
in oceans only ocean community Indonesia
yes way ocean very important and we
discussed in UN about that how ocean can
be useful and more discourage him and
[Music]
this odious we speak about the Hawaii
how Islam Indonesia is moderate middle
part back the history and why different
with Middle East history is nomination
bring by traders not by force not by
military or action or everywhere by
traders mostly freighters is you the
like to make a compromise they like to
make peacefully transitions compare with
you will go away force of go by years
time the second thing is different is
Indonesia's now owns Democratic compared
with many countries in release who
sometimes very important the tribe try
very important there's this were we a
different way to manage the country and
[Music]
our objectively our philosophy of the
country it's the same with yours we call
it Vanetta Tanganyika its main unity in
diversity this rightly just a pluribus
unum with you the same we have same
philosophy of how to manage the whole
country resist beside the history of
course
different island sometimes different
cultures this way unity if we if you see
my friend here using buttock no one
buttock same color
no one wattage same of all difference
but we are unity is this meaning or
Troodon but how Indonesia turn manage
the differentially T between Indonesia
if you see in the nation tourists
articles or campaigning first thing you
see Bali or borobudur we are majority
Muslim but the icon of Indonesia to the
abroad is Hindu and Buddhist borobudur
big temples of Buddhist and Bali
mostly Hindu and he is showing this way
important view first thing go to the
Hindu area that's why we are very easy
if we in middle is now on in Syria I
think all temple heaven destroy but we
are our icon of Indonesia in real time
beside that no one country like
Indonesia module Indonesian miss Muslim
is 88% holiday formal holiday there are
sixteen days a year
five of them is Muslims holiday but
there are three Christians see to
Buddhism Buddhist and Buddha's and even
Chinese holiday we are very respected
each other's I
we hope that America next time it'll be
three international holiday will be a
four Mahalo for the country because
Buddhist even less than 1% of population
they have one national holiday for
Buddhists in Indonesia which is one
thing that we respect each others in our
cabinet member there are certified
cabinet members of in Asia all coming
from different region area and
difference rages for all ages have one
minimum have one seat in the cabinet
flow with different parties but it is
very very communicated and knit harmony
about them this is one scene that how to
banish and there are some issue of
course maybe you hear when Jakarta
governor elect non-elect elections
they're Chinese with a very small
community compete but they lost no
problems
this is democratic country this way this
way is my door this way we are usually
instance in middle parts of Islam by
history by education and by practically
in the countries
if we see the other countries now on
especially Middle East or Arab countries
afters our offspring so many countries
have failed or even have a big problems
but one thing very maybe useful research
the old fair countries is Republic here
are Syria Libya edgy too nice
Afghanistan or Republic but the kingdom
is ok one question maybe you should
research here what kind of public why
they lost but the public with
authoritarian leaders is Nelly the same
within doctor but Republic's there
should we have apartment apartment
Aryans or many things they do but they
cannot do it this way the fair countries
is coming dedication now on I think is
Islamophobia
we're aware but I can tell you in never
no no no on any demonstration on only
head HR about religions in Indonesia we
don't never action about Christians or
reform many some conflict Indonesia many
knows as religion conflict it's not
fifteen year ago in unborn one of the
east town of provinces and also
the conflict between finally between
Islam and Christians but the root of the
conflict is not because religions mostly
not it is about equality equality and
about democracy before when Suharto era
they call it democracy but with harmony
the country for instance the provinces
likes Maluku the number of Muslim and
hestians
is nearly the same but many immigrant
coming and the position is 55% of
Muslims and 45 is Christian but there
are become fake what two years conflict
and there are 5000 people die because
this conflict very bad in our history
very bad in the same info so what is
conflict not because religion because
equality in politics because democracy
before in Indonesia governor of course
too simple local Parliament's
but with negotiation in harmony for
instance if governor is Islam in Maluku
area the first governor should be
Christian if president is Christians and
vice governor Islam and the harmony
there never happened within many years
but after
democratic open democracy he after
reform in 2000 98 starting the condition
of record see the winner-take-all
because populations shift because many
coming and then Muslim choose a Google
as governor and many post in government
is Muslim too because the the
winner-take-all and they say the same
here
if Republic and then always house
people's is coming from a republic or
the other thing they follows your idea
in democracy sometimes not suitable for
the cultures of the people there and
like this happen like thing not
discrimination they look it like this
really because but it is happen because
open democracy that we are implemented
in the country who and afters reform but
who I am the religions coming because
some some leaders using the issue of
religion and any issue of religious very
dangerous because no one independent has
you Christian or your Islam's and fight
each others if and a neighborhood
sometimes they fire his hope because
these different religions but the road
reason not Christian this one thing the
issue that democracy should be
transition not directly open is my with
first learn who have after reform that
don't push countries
- democracy was sometimes American Way
democracy is religion here that if
you're not Morrissey and I will destroy
you because this religions not only some
web jihadists democracy - Thank You
Hollis why'd you bombing Iraq
Afghanistan's because the reason is
democracy is very dangerous in many
place in the world about this faith the
democracy is one of religions that you
implemented for many countries in the
world if not democracy this can happen
in our country but without any outside
intervention because no the winner take
all his problems usually is a conflict
because the changes the idea from
harmony to the winner-take-all in the
democracy way this has happened in many
places in the countries but now on after
we understand this better get to harmony
if you will be winning in Govan Orioles
or mayor in some area who is regions is
nearly the same number and there are
Boniface they met plane or Islam
Christian combinations now on this way
this eras safety safe and no security of
the changes the system itself yes
what happened in the Indus head what
happened in the wall now many problems
our radical isms and tourism's because
if you are make a terror first you are
radical usually I mean radical first and
then from radical to terrorism what has
happened in many countries in one scene
that we have very serious discussion in
the UN last yesterday how to solve this
many many things happened why did that
happen
the first thing as I mentioned again why
they radical why they go into suicide
this young man if if the terrorists who
go in suicide what they expect
of course they don't expected money
because he died they don't expect that
political position the governor or
president because he died and for what
why because they expected paradise
heaven if you kill someone you go into
paradise why they do that because the
young generation who living in the
country who is not peace no economy is
not harmed they know who and they see de
novo because his country destroy that's
why all terror is coming from the failed
country not come from the
advanced country example falconry
al-qaeda came will in Afghanistan who
failed because Russia an affiliate us
coming to help but after the believing
and radicalism their because literally
country in NoHo and the people outside
to liquid Laden who is his welcome from
Isis it is am from Syria in Iraq same
happened the fail country wait Iraq fell
because no leadership who I know
leadership because the people's destroy
no hope economy in Iran and the people
outside is angry young young generations
angry because no hope and the leaders of
religion the after depth having to say
that if you are killing your enemy and
you are going to have paradise that's
why they sell paradise very cheap but
this is happening yeah they say one day
they this mine after they win a book
because they thinking a lot of that this
happened why the fell country again a
say because you won't be Iraq very more
than one bombing in Afghanistan and
Vietnam combination more bombing they
compared with War World War two and all
people's problems no hope they radicals
and a terrorist
this is important to say they say what
we shall do yeah because now on if we
are Dara taro
they are only thing this discussion is
where what who and when never us discuss
about why they do that why they do them
and mostly if you see in a Europe the
young man who made a suicide is not
practiced religious in Belgium in France
they sell alcohol they sell drugs and
the other thing but it is short pass to
paradise they're thinking about it and
everybody here of course us is believing
the paradise heaven the and then of
course many things thinking about them
that's why what we do the yuneisia to
generate rise of the deeper is how to
reduce the such ideology in school into
people's in their no se of course it is
telematics more than ten thousands in
jail
Indonesia of all day or six thousand
smaller because radicalism and possible
go into terrorists but we are throw many
theoretical isms in the jail was not
easy to help if you many like deaths in
one gel the gel will be University of
terrorism's if let's use operated in
many jail they make fears of radicalism
in a jail if you know al-baghdadi
Isis leaders they radicals after they
living in jail in Europe by US jail and
very more radicalism after death
this is this is matter of the world how
to reduce mechanisms by making the
country not fair
if we compare what problem now in Iraq
compared with sometimes as I see most
people more better life went down
compared now on if you compare in Libya
which one Qaddafi or now on no no
government at all no law at all
everybody can shoot anybody in Iraq and
Iran this is one thing don't know the
problems again democratization which
force is not is useless
this way democracy will come by welfare
by unity of the wall to make our program
to reduce welfare to to increase welfare
to reduce poor view anything as we call
the STDs that's why the UN program USD
G's is very very important for
mannequins really God this is one thing
that we should understand and I think I
hope that the easy way to invasion of
any countries on behalf of ideologies is
not easier because you cannot fight the
ideology by force because in his mind
the only thing you change the mind by
mind to by ideology where the equations
by by environment
by Stewie bye-bye if you hear to do
don't study that religions is democracy
for religions this is what's in happen
everywhere Muslim of posts like
Indonesian Muslims if very moderate is
can be operate with the other but when
we see it directly needed of course
understanding each other's the national
ideology who have William writes our
it'll be negative the Gita or you are us
whom legislation Smith should be
compared I think University very
important thing to teach more about
harmony in between the area harmony how
to balancing the needs of the industry
life and the needs how after life
because if only thinking about after
life and then you will be jihadists but
if you are thinking about life and
afterlife I think you will have a
harmony in between in between and this
way who hope here to Columbia University
have a good how about making a example
how to because your students come from
everywhere in the world will be happy
unity if they are good example what we
do in the here I think
again thank you very much for this and
bless lest unity to walk about it
that not easy don't don't invasions any
country in return tree the force because
you have force and your evasion you
bombing any countries that know nothing
happened there because only
miscalculation or intelligence not
enough enough fact fact about it but we
hope neurons yeah many thing of course
the or neurons leader sometimes there
are very good there are some we don't
know what they do like North Korea don't
know no one can analyze what would they
want to do but sometime here - we are
foreign country sometimes very confused
what you will do this way you hope the
head University can explain to us what
we will do what what we are going to go
because if you we know what we are you
going to go and then we can together
unless in the world in this happen don't
because if he only can of course we
condemn of course we are sorry there are
one bomb being 10 dies in London's or in
Paris but but in same time you see
imagine 1 million people die in this
area in Iraq how many million the
refugees were everywhere in the world
because unbelievable reasons they are go
there anyway it's the same when I saw
last night our faith no war in TV and a
Kaffir controversies why you go to
witness without any good reason to delay
so please the understanding we are in
the country far away from here in the
rain
but needed to harmony life with not only
with intonation people with all people
involved and sometimes education very
important to make a Harmonia life
whether again thank you very much for
all your students thank you
so I'm Andy Nathan and I'll be
moderating the Q&A I would invite where
are the mics that people are supposed to
line up at there should be mics I don't
see them but here they come
so I would ask you to line up if you
would like to ask a question identify
yourself
keep the quickly your name and the
school that you're in and keep your
question brief if you would and I'll
just start by thanking vice president
color for a very very substantive set of
remarks quick good criticisms of US
policy that are politely stated and
highly persuasive and I think we might
try to persuade our political leaders to
wear more batik and and if I could ask
the first question myself you indicated
in your remarks that that democracy
sometimes drives conflict among groups
because it's winner-take-all
and leaders will use religion to
mobilize their supporters but you also
said that when there's a sufficient
amount of welfare in a society democracy
will work okay I think I heard you say
that so I wanted to know whether you
think that democracy can work well in
Indonesia or whether you feel that at
the present time it it is detrimental to
Indonesia yes
democracy can practices Indonesia
because the culture in historical where
Indonesia is unity different but unity
to and against we are our historical
very transitionals changes no
revolutionary changes as they say even
in indonesia buddhist less than 1% of
population but the icon of our country
if the tourists is birudo it's same like
india india majority Hindu but I can
touch Mahalo his Muslims identity in
India not Hindu rajma and why don't walk
like minikin Islam many in Middle East
because history or position is tribes
tribes needed a leader leader small
either young very important to the
tribes only Saudi attorney and tribe or
tribes Indonesian no one such family can
control Indonesia this will change every
five years like known except that times
are 250 30 years but no no no more
beside the attesa you mentioned that
democracy should be have to transition
because why again my question is why the
country who have Arab Spring effect in
the Middle East mostly Republic not
Kingdom six seven of them is Republic
because its meaning there no bockris
eggs are you too expressing you in
dependency to speak but leaders they
look like him as a king to and thence
not matching between the peoples and the
readers but Indonesia your choice by
people
directly you'll be responsible of them
thank you so much let's go to this mic
first identify yourself and your school
Salam aleikum surah al mualim I thank
you so much for coming here and talking
about such relevant issues my name is
Soha karmani I'm from the School of
Continuing Professional Studies and I'm
doing a master's in sustainability
management so you spoke about harmony
and respect and living together in peace
I wanted to know what your country is
doing for the gay and transgender
community to enable them to live in
peace and harmony thank thank you yes of
course as I was say that the first thing
is do direct do it's not only say that
if you say that all people have a good
opportunity because no different of
regions this way all cabinet have order
a Hindu there are Chinese there I'm a
Christian
they're a Muslim of course it is it is
happened every government in the
countries like that new year every
holiday should be combination here I
think Muslim is more than 1% of
operations here in you know make I don't
know that but no of course Islam holiday
here of course not
even the same no Hindus holidays but we
do it you see me we respect each others
by doing they say we can do it harmony
in many place about it but specifically
about the sexual minorities the LGBT
lesbian gay bisexual transgender that
particular issue
yeah there are you know the first
meeting of LGBT is in doctor
in Indonesia I don't know why didn't
initially but of course Indonesia is 80%
of Muslim land even more mostly of
religious leaders don't accept it as
former life
sometimes we know someone LGBT bus okay
you are you do it as personals but don't
do it like a community community okay
hello thank you for being here with us
mr. vice president
my name is aina and I'm here an exchange
scholar for the human rights advocate
program I'm an Indonesian and I'm very
proud of being Indonesian I'm really
scared to ask this question really
because even though I see so many
Indonesian wedding party it makes me
feel intimidated because this really
hard question for me okay so I'm feel
saddened by the recent situation in
Indonesia particularly in the rise with
the rise of increasing of Islamist
extremists in our society it's getting
worse now because they used violence
hate speech fake news and now they use
the propaganda of communism again so
even though they are in small group but
they have power more than the government
and the police at least that is in my
opinion in 2013 we have a book
discussion in Jogjakarta I am and my
friends were beaten hundreds of people
coming and beaten us keep it short and
asked question yeah until today they
never held accountable for this so my
equation why the government is so weak
when confronting with this Islamic
extremists and in terms of democracy in
harmony I don't agree with harmony
because that is what they use to us
usually the police asked us to cancel
the event because having different
opinion means written harm
and that's far for me harmony main
street and democracy which group were
you representing when you were beaten
I'm the woman's group movement at the
time we discussed about lesbian and gay
in Islam okay thank you
it's very good questions about that and
harmony is still under law
no one free at all for harmony same here
too of course everywhere you may follow
for instance you say about communists
this there are law in 2000 saying that
that pet ie a multipolar party is banned
in the countries it's nothing do it with
harmony with a row because harmony Tony
did low if not all no harmony do this
why because this bended below not and
pendants you cannot go in campaigning or
talking about how calm this party will
be in the countries the second thing
about once a LGBT or consider it is not
only Indonesia many countries I think
even in in America not all states as can
can afford that in the formal way as I
mentioned LGBT in personal way it's not
problems in Indonesia we know there
someone but if you were going to format
it is not again it's against about
religious what a religion you have it is
a it is banned everywhere
that's why harmony is me that if you do
something that making the people come
free
is unharmed moaning note because we
allow you to harmony but we prevent and
harmony in the people's way
the harmony is not being that all you
free anything to do because they are low
on that thank you
this mic here there's nobody at this mic
so I encourage you people on the that
side to line up hello yeah someone I
come from home swash tears - my name is
a grandpa I'm from Aceh Indonesia more
Chinese people you are very well-known
as one of the heroes for making the
peace agreement between our Chi and
Indonesian government happening so thank
you for that my questions to you what is
the secret after 50 years of civil war
between the Indonesian government and
Archer and we had the peace agreement
what is the secret behind behind it and
my second question is that you know
listening to your speech Indonesia is
very peaceful right now my question is
what makes you awake at night what is
the biggest challenge that you are
facing right now as the vice president
of Indonesia thank you yes thank you for
your appreciations we do conflict in
Aceh is 30 years around 20,000 people
have died because these conflicts and
[Music]
there are pushing everywhere what we do
first thing they study about the route
of the coffee many say that conflict in
Aceh because religion way no no I said
no because economy arch a very rich with
natural resources more than gas
very biggest project in a chain but are
Chinese people thinking why we are very
rich but we don't enjoy that the
national renewal natural gas and oil gas
they say when we are meeting firstly
solve the problems of how the other
people can enjoy anything using natural
resources for the articles this way or
national law say that if 100 productions
15% going to the provinces itself 15%
but we change por aqui
there are checked and enjoy open take it
17% 75% of natural resource is magic and
the other side is that with I say this
is one one thing to euros solve the
conflict is no one should will cross
face if you negotiation than the other
lost face no no no discussion no
solution that's why it's not a last
night I met president Columbia and
because before they asked me to talk to
him to spare about how to do the piece
you see is really what drew problems
what don't make a solution without loss
facing each other's this way if you say
sacra for me not sacred is the way they
give solution in the root of the
problems no religion problem energy but
the help or the helpee whole happy use
the natural resources therefore at least
be preserved and the second thing met a
solution with win-win with
each other's this way I chicken dissolve
after 30 years thank you very much and
in the challenge of Indonesia yes yes
first in poverty and of course education
sometimes here why we send how many
people go to overseas to study because
the problem is poverty thank you for
being here mr. vice president my name is
Avinash Ravikumar I'm a mechanical
engineering master student and so my
questions about the Paris climate
Accords and Indonesia's role in that so
before the climate records there was
certain concern that Indonesia may not
sign on and that Indonesia might not if
it does sign on hold up it's part of the
agreement and like contribute its fair
share so but it looks like Indonesia is
moving forward on that right now and so
my question is considering Indonesia's
dedication to upholding the Paris
climate records what is your role or
what are your future policies on the
coal industry as that has been a
significant industry sector yes in the
ratio joining and intend to implement
that the Paris Accord is very important
and one thing important for Tunisia in
these stuffy tropical forests in Tunisia
one of the biggest country in the world
have are tropical forests or rainforests
beside Brazil before in before 17th of
1916 we have 150 million hectare of
rainforest Indonesia but then coming big
company to teach the people how to come
before the very first tertiary to sell
foods and the other thing starting with
Georgia
Fick pro-america Marubeni most busi
cause if he Hyundai from Korea and they
come around 90 millions hectare of
forest rainforest and many many things
that there are landslides or crude
because there you have some of course
very cheap money on debt before that's
why we are we intention for intention to
how the Paris Accord implemented but
very sorry that US is self tram nor the
u.s. Trump's I have say no they do not
agree with price core anymore very pity
for us to do that because for me for
Indonesia tropical forest rainforest not
only for the people in Asia for him
about call-call 50 percent of
electricity duration is still using coal
for primary energy it's the same here in
the u.s. called sports importance to do
that we are now have a policy that until
20 years from now on the renewable
energy will be much implemented
consisting like he draw and redraw
powers or water Mars
I mean wins or the others renewable
energy now very big very big campaign to
do that in Eurasia and reduces for only
if mine mouth call electric power not in
the near City that's what we do in this
how to reduce call effect like China
that Beijing is sometimes of free cloudy
if there are this this call effect
thank you thank you yeah farm alaikum
alaikum Salaam
my name is Makaha sonali and i'm a
freshman in columbia college for many
Muslims around the world and political
analysts alike the way that Indonesia
has blended Islam and politics is very
admirable however that is not the case
for other Muslim countries there's this
disconnect between what some countries
to Saudi Arabia Iran and the like and I
was wondering what do you think are the
most important factors and you need
unifying the Muslim world so that we can
face the common issues that's terrorism
some phobia cetera yes I mentioned
before it democracy is one thing good
system but not the most best systems in
whatever we do especially in Middle East
that not easy to you to implement that
the democracy is like what do you do
here in US or the other countries
democracy way is many many style mock
receipts maybe sometimes you you can
mystery about Arab democracies or like
China like Japan to is different India
is different Mockridge they they
implemented several Indonesia
that's why how to make in this was I
think I think less let's go on and make
free relative the country to be better
understanding about how and stopping big
country to enhance orals making big
problems in any country like Iraq or
Syria or India in the other countries
stopping in Afghanistan and less make
negotiation is very importance of peace
there is no easy to say but of course
needed hard work to make a peace in many
countries we have time for just one more
question I'm sorry
that would go to this side well mr. vice
president thank you for your comment
it's very heartening to hear the great
achievements Indonesia has made in peace
harmony and democracy I'm wondering if
we could comment on the regional
security issues in Indonesia and kind of
ASEAN in general had historical warm
relations with North Korea what you see
is a row of Indonesia in the current
North Korean crisis and closer to
Indonesia South China Sea issues hersel
pretty hot in international discussion
in the what do you see as the role of
Indonesia and ASEAN at large in
resolving conflicts thank you yes no
much country like Indonesia who have
good duration the duration for South
Korea and North Korea we have all
ambassador there in the two countries
who is because the historical when
Suharto Colonel era in 1516 they have a
good relation with Pyongyang this why
president Megawati the daughters of
process sukarno sometimes law both the
area to discuss but we don't know what
they want it's it is not easy to talk to
people too young everybody if we don't
know what they want what they want give
me your on this no one's Express Eisley
why they do that in very proper very
poverty there but they make a nuclear if
you are rich and make nuclear bomb I
think okay logic but how the country who
economy is very low but very peppy any
people to make rocket and the Ellison's
show expensive that's why I cannot say
because we don't know what they want if
I know what you are what you want and
then you really discuss what you want
this is problems there
lady North Korea even though Indonesia
have good relation work about South
China Sea yes there are so many things
tension there but I don't believe China
will be made of problems in South China
Seas because why China is industrial
countries any industrial countries
needed training need business need
import/export sixty percent of export of
America of China is through socialism if
there are war there also all 60 percent
of China export will be stopped and the
country will collapse that's why I don't
believe that China will be made a force
to China but maybe there are natural
resources which there and they can make
it with those territorial area as you
well mr. vice president we have to wrap
up I want to thank you on behalf of the
audience and the University for sharing
your big thoughts and also your very
practical political wisdom with us today
and answering some some tough questions
at the University we we use intellectual
conflicts to try to work our way toward
long-term harmony we're not there yet
but these kinds of discussions are very
valuable to us so thank you please join
me in thanking vice president Pilate